traverser au bonhomme rouge quand il n'y
a pas deux voitures la tentation est
grande mais le danger toujours présent
c'est ce qu'a souhaité rappeler la
police lors d'une opération de
prévention jeudi 12 janvier
une action menée suite aux différents
accidents survenus récemment deux
accidents très préoccupant a
en fin d'année pour une personne se
trouvant sur un passage piétons passant
au vert a été renversé par un véhicule
qui passait lui aussi au vert mais
débouchant d'une autre artère est très
récemment la semaine passée un jeune
garçon de 14 ans qui traverse en venant
de la gare pour prendre un bus a
traversé la chaussée au rouge piétons et
bien sûr s'est fait renverser par
malheureusement deux véhicules
antérieurs sont sept chauffeurs
l'an dernier ce piéton ont perdu la vie
dans le département une augmentation de
50% par rapport à 2015 une dizaine de
policiers nationaux et municipaux ont
donc stoppé les imprudents aux abords de
l'avenue du centre de montigny le
bretonneux
aujourd'hui les conditions météo ne sont
pas bonnes les gens sont souvent
habillés en sont emmitouflés dans des
capuches et sous des parapluies ce qui
diminue fortement leur champ de
visibilité leur perception des dangers
de la route
le but de l'opération aujourd'hui n'est
pas de sanctionner mais de sensibiliser
les piétons aux risques qu'ils prennent
en traversant la chaussée sans respecter
la sinisation sont respectées le
marquage au sol
je pensais avoir le temps de passer
avant que alors capitaux ou de laine
rouge
donc j'ai mal jugé des agents en civil
ont également relevé les infractions des
véhicules
un refus de priorité à un piéton est
sanctionné par un retrait de quatre
points sur le permis de conduire et 135
euros d'amande